I think right back to the stand is
whatever you walked in and we started up
with this idea of contrasting I'm going
to go on HTTP one on you contrasting
annuities and compound interest they are
very closely related
but there's one crucial difference I say
but there's compounding happening in
both a lot of people asking oh I saw the
question said compounding so I went to
the compound interest formula if you
look at a table with annuities it's
doing all the compounding for you
so compounding is not the difference
what is the difference between an
annuity versus just a regular bank
account with compound
yeah and you use actually yeah very good
you continually add right you keep on
pumping more money into it every year
versus what is what happens in its
regular competitors yeah you put money
in there's an initial term or an initial
principal rather and no further funds
right you just let it sit there okay now
this this dichotomy is that very good
explore in this present value idea okay
um present value is other third best in
contrast to future though right so let's
just make up some numbers and see what
happens as an example right find the
future value
Oh ten dollars actually commit look
different area sometimes look good for
my development right um how long would
you like to invest assaulting sections
like butter sorry what that's a pattern
oh okay five years now pick an interest
rate for me that's on your table because
we're going to use the table five years
at what like and it's trip two cents on
there is it chipset
yeah at three percent per annum for five
years so no fancy stuff with quarters or
months or anything like that okay go to
the table I want you to find where the
five years down the road is and go
across to the three percent column to
find the future value the future value
is going to be equal to one hundred
dollars times what number say at one
point five point one is five point by
the way for getting because every five
years the minimum is gonna be fine right
so five boys three oh nine one we've got
in here okay right so because they chose
a nice simple number this is just
getting five hundred and thirty dollars
and ninety one cents yep okay now this
is the future though okay but what
present value is about is about
imagining okay well what about would
hire have had to invest today by the way
it's a crucial Center someone are pins
again are we got to write it in a minute
present value use what about what I have
to invest today like it is just put down
a salt and interesting let go so that it
ends up at the same value let me say
that again elevated together okay
present value present value is what some
what principle
must be invested just at compound
interest so I'm not going to continually
put lots of lots of money in I'm just
going to put it in and then let it sit
for the stand at a time and the same
interest rate it already gets you the
same end goal okay what principle must
be invented that invested as the same
interest rate and for the same length of
time to result in the same future none
okay so what I'm trying to picture it is
but what if I can't continually put in
money what would it look like to just
put it in there let it sit until it gets
the same amount obviously it's going to
be significantly larger because you're
not doing that continual reinvestment or
how much how would we do this we're
going to have to sort of reverse
engineer its compound interesting right
the present value present value is going
to be some amount right if I can learn
now I'll leave it like that
it's going to be some amount I'm just
going to call this which is a good down
from redditors
this is called X for now so this is my
Hungary and it's going to do the
compound interest in based on the same
figures that I had before right so what
goes into the compound interest oil
what's in the bracket my variance 1 plus
my chosen interest rate you guys chose R
through 10 well I just subtract I refuse
then the five years also goes somewhere
in the comment earlier right where to go
how I here's the power it is now you're
so used to seeing I this printer will be
given to you I'm investing this amount
then I'm putting in for this rate for
that one but the whole point is I want
to know what about to put in the video
that's what present value means so
therefore I've actually got to change
the subject a little bit this final
value is already known look at the
question what we've already done
where are we going to end up
that big guns okay so now I'm going to
rearrange I'm going to make extra
subject which is actually really easy
all I have to do is divide stood by that
so the present value will be 907 really
gonna do it
sorry about that to make you impossible
okay yep let's see that is there are two
things I want to point out number one of
this sum is enormous compared to the
original self
why continuty this is an annuity so it
gets put in many times that many times
right this guy just has to sit there for
a long time okay but what this means is
but what are you told you keep on
putting you if you don't notice you
don't have access to math anymore just
put in disappears on your salary what
it's really meaning to you is this
amount right if I decide today I want to
put in the hundred dollars and keep on
doing that what I'm really actually
getting out of that what really is worth
in this amount that is present value if
it were in for that amount of time
that's the first I want to point out if
this number is so much larger the second
thing is I really cut midterms off if
you put your reference sheet there I saw
a lot of you had it downloaded so you
can actually refer to it I want to point
your attention to and I'll hold it up in
a second just so most of you can see on
a check which paint it is let's notice
sorry the present value and future value
formulas you will find on the very first
page in fact I'll go watch this so
that's big enough that you can mostly
see it even says it's labeled present
value and future value right so which
one if we just don't have a look and
have a look at the board there it is
right there
present value equals future value at the
top divided by and there's your compound
interest it's just doing its normal
thing does that make sense so this is a
bit tricky but you've got this year is a
bit of a glide all that really means
that you we're trying to convert one of
these into one of these and that's what
this process is about very frequently
you'll be required to work out the
future value first and then backtrack
but you've got the floor you're there
for the exact reason that you can
actually go straight there if you know
what this future value is you can work
out the present value straight away with
your for bed
[Music]